Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone. Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Forehead, excellent. So, Leute, auf geht's.
Ich bin ein bisschen länger gepennt als sonst.
Dance Game.
In your face, allein.
Und dann soll ich mal was sagen. Ich hab auf YouTube den letzten halben Monat mehr Subs gemacht als das letzte Jahr zusammen, als ich schon wieder was hochgeladen hab.
Ich hab mittlerweile fast 600 Subs gemacht und wir sind bei minus 500 gestartet, weil wenn du nichts machst auf YouTube, dann verlierst du ja mit der Zeit immer mehr Leute.
Und ich verliere so ungefähr 500, 500, 400 bis 600 Subs so im Monat. Jetzt ist es fast schon wieder plus.
Also ab und zu mal ein bisschen regelmäßig Content machen lohnt sich.
Und wisst ihr was mich freut, was echt Massive Pog ist?
Und zwar was Massive Pog ist, ich zeig es euch mal.
Game up, acht Monate Dankeschön für den Sub. Huge IQ Subscription, dass das Video so gut ankommt.
Guckt mal hier, Informatiker reagiert auf IT Stellenanzeigen. 42K in fünf Tagen, das ist nicht schlecht.
Und das haben halt viele Leute gefunden über die YouTube-Suche. Das heißt, es war eine gute Idee das Video zu machen.
Und auch die anderen Sachen werden relativ oft geguckt. Hier hätte ich mir eigentlich gedacht, das ist auch ganz interessant, aber das hat nicht so viele Leute gejuckt.
Wobei ich das eigentlich übelst lustig fand. Aber es ist nichts für den Mainstream wahrscheinlich.
So, heute mache ich ein Battlefield-Video mit den Nachtmaps. Brauche ich noch irgendwie... Leute, wenn einer Big Brain rote Pfeile Clickbait-Titel-Idee hat für das Battlefield-Nachtmap-Videos, schreibt mal in den Chat.
Das muss irgendwas sein, was jetzt nicht total realitätsfern ist. Also ich werde jetzt... Das war ja gestern nur ein Witz, ne? Also ich werde jetzt nicht machen...
Noshak-Candles-Gone-Dark-Gone-Wrong-Gone-Sexual. Ist auch offens lustig schwer, weil ich glaube erst die meisten Leute verstehen den Gag gar nicht. Und das klickt auch keiner an, weil keiner checkt, was ich ihnen sagen will.
Deswegen, das geht nicht. Ich brauche da irgendeinen guten Titel für... Gameplay habe ich genug. Also ich würde wahrscheinlich mittlerweile 40 Minuten Gameplay voll kriegen, aber das brauche ich gar nicht.
Warte mal kurz.
Excellent, wieder da. Ja, also falls irgend einer Massive-Brained-Idee hat für ein neues Battlefield-Video. Ich weiß noch gar nicht so genau, was ich erzählen will. Ich werde wahrscheinlich die Nachtmaps nehmen und einfach erzählen, wie geil das ist, wenn die Hersteller mal ein bisschen mehr Mod-Möglichkeiten einbauen würden. Und wie gut das Ganze geworden ist. Allerdings halt noch einiges fehlt. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen.
Hast du das Linus-Tech-Tips-Video mit Electro-Boom gesehen? Ja, fand ich langweilig.
Fand ich nicht so eigentlich toll. Ja, aufwachen und streamen, so sieht es aus. Also wir brauchen irgendeinen nice Battlefield-Clickbait-Titel, der nicht unrealistisch Clickbait ist. Also der darf frisch Clickbait sein, aber nicht unrealistisch Clickbait.
Also nicht sowas, Battlefield verändert dein Leben, Coaches hassen diesen Trick oder irgendwie sowas. Nee, nee, muss schon irgendwas realistisches sein.
Übrigens, ihr findet ja eigentlich meine Thumbnails mittlerweile. Die sind halt total random, ne? Also ich glaube an meine Thumbnails ist nichts einheitlich. Das ist einfach random zusammengeklickt irgendwie mittlerweile.
Wieso BF6 kacke wird? Ich sage in dem ganzen Video wahrscheinlich vielleicht einen Satz zu Battlefield 6. Auf der anderen Seite, glaube ich interessiert das gar nicht so viele.
Die stechen in der Ammo-Box raus, findest du? EA zittert, weil der Mod... Oh, das ist eine gute Idee. Sowas in der Richtung. Das ist natürlich für YouTube noch zu kompliziert geschrieben.
Die Leute auf YouTube können teilweise nur zur Hälfte lesen. Hab ich den Eindruck? Also das müsste was sein. Vernichtet dieser Mod Dice oder vernichtet dieser Mod Battlefield oder vernichtet dieser Mod EA.
Irgendwie sowas. Alter, ernsthaft? Haben die Lochis neun? Na zum Glück nicht. Ich war schon kurz geschockt. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, das hat sich erledigt mittlerweile. Aber nein, das ist immer noch am Start.
Wisst ihr, dass mich die Lochis abonniert haben seit 2011? Massive. Kann ich stolz drauf sein. Easy. Ach komm, wir gucken mal noch. Wir gucken noch ne Runde. Epic 2. Excellent.
EA zittert, Mod übernimmt die Welt. Ja, das ist gut. Das ist gut. Wer das nicht guckt, wird weggecockt. Das wird wahrscheinlich gleich entmonetarisiert auf YouTube.
Habt ihr das auf Twitch mitgekriegt? Also ich kann das jetzt nicht im Stream zeigen, weil das ist Monkathos. Aber irgendeine weibliche Streamerin hat auf Twitch ihren nackten Hintern und nicht nur ihren nackten Hintern in die Kamera gehalten.
Weil sie angeblich ein Onlyfans-Video aufnehmen wollte und dabei aus Versehen auch streamen geklickt hat anstatt auf aufnehmen. Also die hatten wie gesagt nicht nur die Hintern, die hatten einfach komplett alles in die Kamera gedrückt, was so gibt.
Und wisst ihr was sie gekriegt hat? 3 Tage Mann. Halt mal aus Versehen das Ding in die Kamera, Alter. Da ist Instant Band für immer am Start. Ja, der Chat weiß es. Der Chat weiß es, 3 Tage Mann.
Also manchmal hab ich echt den Eindruck, da wird so mit zweierlei Maß gemessen. Irgendeiner sagt im Eifer des Gefechts war ein falsches Wort. Bam, Woche weg.
Hälst deinen kompletten Genitalbereich ins Video, egal, easy, 3 Tage Mann. Wenn du weiblich bist natürlich, ja. Gut mal davon abgesehen, ich glaube so viele männliche Streamer mit Onlyfans-Account, wo sie dann sowas reinstellen, gibt es auch nicht, weil wer guckt sich das an?
Da haben Mädels schon einen Vorteil, ne? Also was Onlyfans-Accounts angeht, da kannst du als männlicher Streamer nicht so viel machen. Zumal man ja auch mal ehrlich sagen muss, die meisten männlichen Streamer sehen kacke aus.
Nicht alle, aber die meisten wünschen mir nicht unbedingt Onlyfans-Accounts an. Von mir auch nicht, ja. Das ist wirklich passiert, ja, ja.
Ich hab den Eindruck, es gibt, also wie gesagt, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regeln, es gibt auch genug, die wirklich ordentlich Content machen. Aber ich hab den Eindruck, es gibt seit so 2-3 Jahren so eine zunehmende Anzahl von Streamerinnen auf Twitch.
Das einzige, der einzige Inhalt dieses Streams ist quasi, dass sie gut aussehen. Ansonsten gibt es da nichts zu holen, Alter.
Ich sag Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regeln, es gibt auch genug andere, aber es nimmt immer mehr zu. Ihr müsst nur mal abends auf Twitch gehen und gebt mal ASMR ein und guckt euch das an. Alter.
Das grenzt ja, das überschreitet ja fast schon die Grenze zum Softporno, was da auch was zu sehen gibt.
Nee, nee. Ganz schön sneaky weiß Bescheid, ich sehs.
Äh, bin ich heute leiser als sonst? Nee, oder? So wie immer. Ich glaub, ich hör einfach nur schlechter. Nee, ich bin sogar ein bisschen lauter als sonst. Lull.
Guck mal, ich übersteuer. Hau mal, steuer ich. Was ist hier los? Moment.
Da stimmt was nicht. Test, Test, Test. Nee. Hä? Alter, OBS, was los? Moment, Moment, Moment.
Hat mich das wieder verstellt?
By the way, find's auch geil, dass du das hier erstmal ausfahren musst. Ach nee, sonst stehts da unten.
Äh, Moment, Moment. Hab ich. Zwo? What the fuck? Warum steht das auf 82? Das soll nicht auf 82, das ist falsch.
Warum hat sich das umgestellt? Ich hatte nichts offen, was das macht. Hä?
Das steht normalerweise immer auf 71. Deswegen, deswegen hab ich auch so übersteuert.
Warum? Ich hab noch nicht mal Teams offen gehabt, ne? Gar nichts.
Und jetzt hat sich das einfach verstellt. Welches Game könnte mein Mikrofon verstellen?
Man weiß es nicht. Chrome? Chrome? Ernsthaft? Aber, nee normalerweise macht das Chrome nicht.
Naja, also. Aber Chrome wahrscheinlich nur, wenn du. Also wenn ich Teams laufen lasse über Chrome.
Ja, aber ansonsten einfach so random.
Mastari sagt, dein Video über die Lebensweisheit war echt gut, hat mir geholfen. Nice.
Das war ja so eine spontane Sache. Ich wollte ja eigentlich gar nichts aufnehmen am 24.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, komm, das ist ein Thema, da wolltest du schon länger mal was zu sagen.
Und ich hätte mir ehrlich gesagt, ich hätte noch ein paar Sachen mehr sagen müssen.
Also hätte ich mir mal ein, zwei Stunden Gedanken vorher gemacht, ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben,
dann hätte ich manche Sachen auch besser erklären können, wie ich das meine.
Aber ja gut, ich war halt spontan aufgenommen, ja.
Zum Beispiel haben manche Leute aus meinem Video rausgehört, also ich meine das da,
haben ein paar Leute, ähm, echt, Chrome verändert das einfach so? The fuck? Warum?
Alter, Google Shit. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Zum Beispiel haben es manche Leute so verstanden, dabei wollte ich eigentlich genau das Gegenteil sagen.
So nach dem Motto, es wäre ja gar nicht so gut, wenn man auf andere Leute gar nicht mehr hört,
weil vielleicht sagen die ja manchmal was Sinnvolles, genau das wollte ich eigentlich mit dem Video sagen.
Also unter anderem, ja. So nach dem Motto, diese ganzen Videos, die die erzählen, so nach dem Motto,
man soll komplett drauf scheißen, was andere Leute über einen sagen, finde ich stimmt gar nicht.
Es gibt durchaus Leute, die ab und zu mal was Sinnvolles sagen und da kann man dann auch drauf hören.
Ich meine zum Beispiel, der Patrick hat es glaube ich in den Kommentarbereich geschrieben, ja.
Also wenn jeder sagt, Alter der Max ist ja voll der Spaß, dann ist da vielleicht auch was dran.
Natürlich kann ich jetzt sagen, ja juckt mich nicht, ihr könnt mich alle machen.
Kann ich machen, aber vielleicht ist ja was dran. Ja und auch so ein paar andere Sachen.
Aber hätte ich mir im Vorfeld mal ein bisschen was überlegen müssen,
aber ich habe gesagt, ich habe es halt spontan aufgenommen.
Oh, habe ich das Delay rausgemacht? Moment, habe ich jetzt Delay?
Sieht doch hier Stream-Statistik.
Low Latency, okay.
Latency, okay eine Sekunde, ich habe das Delay raus.
Exzellent, sehr gut.
Ah ja, okay was gucken wir uns als erstes an?
MW2 smallest Nintendo 64, das Video habe ich einfach aufgemacht, weil das Thumbnail gut aussah.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da jetzt eigentlich gleich kommt.
Ah ja und ich habe gestern ein bisschen an meinem Mixer aus Versehen rumgestellt,
weil mich jemand über Twitter gefragt hat, PN, ob ich über meine Settings sagen könnte.
Bei ihm funktioniert es nicht so richtig, habe ich gemacht und dann habe ich rumgedreht am Mixer
und nachher ist mir aufgefallen, es war ziemlich doof.
Ich habe mir nämlich vorher kein Foto von gemacht oder aufgeschrieben,
auf welchen Settings ich stehen habe und habe versucht wieder das Ganze zu rekonstruieren,
aber ich glaube es hört sich ungefähr so an wie immer.
MW2, Nintendo 64, aber wir können wieder ein bisschen Schloss öffnen zugucken.
Alter dieses Ding, das ist so hässlich das Teil.
Guckt euch das mal an, das sieht aus als hätten irgendwelche Banggood und AliExpress Chinesen versucht
einen externen Festplattenrahmen zu designen.
Es wurde etwas verändert, naja ich habe es versucht so einzustellen, dass man nicht hört,
dass sich etwas verändert hat, also umso mehr man es nicht hört, umso besser.
Hast du eigentlich, nee, Alter, habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht.
Was war dein erster richtiger, oh das willst du nicht wissen,
mein erster richtiger Job war überhaupt nichts IT-mäßiges.
Ich habe mal in meinem vorherigen Leben so eine BWL-Stonks-Geschichte gemacht,
also angefangen zu lernen und, Alter so ein Kack.
Deswegen habe ich wahrscheinlich auch die Abneigung gegen sowas.
Zumindest, ich habe mir da ja so ein paar Sachen, ich habe mir so ein paar Sachen daraus gemerkt.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, ich kann die Buchhalternase, ja ganz wichtig,
das ist das essenziellste, was man wissen muss, die Buchhalternase.
Und ich habe mir gemerkt, dass man Abschreibungen linear und degressiv machen kann, alles klar.
Das wolltet ihr sicherlich schon immer mal wissen.
Und ich habe aber gemerkt, als ich das, da habe ich das gemacht, ungefähr ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre habe ich das gemacht,
habe ich gemerkt, dass mir dieser ganze BWL-Kram so unglaublich auf den Sack geht,
habe ich kein Mod mal drauf gehabt.
Und seitdem, ohne scheiß Leute, seitdem mache ich einen riesen Bogen,
um alles was irgendwelche BWL-Sachen bei sich mit zu tun hat.
Das ist einfach nichts, einfach nicht meins.
Ja genau, also was ich euch zeigen wollte, das ist der hässlichste,
das ist echt der hässlichste Single-Board-Computer mit Gehäuse, den es gibt.
Guckt euch das mal an, Alter!
Was ist, was soll das sein, ey?
Das ist so unglaublich hässlich, das Teil.
Und vorne...
Und vorne ist noch so ein hässliches AliExpress-Display dran.
Ey, das ist so schlecht, Alter.
Oh...
Guck mal, das sieht original aus, als hat das irgendeiner auf AliExpress aus Ersatzteilen zusammengebaut.
Und jetzt verkaufen die wirklich so.
Ja, es sieht aus wie ein 56K-Moder im Gehäuse.
Ja, so sieht es wirklich aus.
Nee, also ernsthaft.
Also was die geritten hat beim...
Es hat was von einem Toaster, ja, es hat wirklich was von einem Toaster.
Battlefield 3 vielleicht schon Mittag wieder, oder heute Abend, mal gucken.
Aber das wird schwierig, weil ich muss noch das Battlefield-Video aufnehmen heute.
Und ich will mit ein paar Leuten mal ein bisschen Black Ops Zombies spielen, aber nicht on stream.
Zombie-Gameplay eignet sich auch super für den Hintergrund.
Genauso, auf Dog, genau. Ich hätte gerne einen Raspberry Pi und dann sagt die Mutter, nein, wir haben doch einen Raspberry Pi zu Hause.
Und dann kommt sie mit so einem Ding an.
An sich sind die Specks gar nicht mal so scheiße, ja, das ist eigentlich sogar ganz gut.
Aber ohne scheiß das Gehäuse in der Kombination mit diesem Ding...
Ich meine, hätte man nicht wenigstens das Gehäuse noch nicht durchsichtig machen können.
Video im Stream aufnehmen.
Ich glaube, das geht nicht, da kann ich mich nicht konzentrieren.
Oh, ich bin noch in Battlefield 3, hups, hups.
Moment, Just Chatting, ich bin noch in Battlefield 3, WTF?
Jetzt habe ich umgestellt, da habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Scam-Arst, Alter.
So, hat er das jetzt umgeschaltet.
Alter, wie mich diese The Boys Werbung nervt, ne.
Das ist immer die gleiche, die haben nur einen Trailer.
So, jetzt ist Just Chatting, naja.
Ich glaube, das geht sogar in dem Fall.
Ich habe nämlich den Vorgänger und ich vermute mal, dass da intern gar nicht so viel...
Also ich gehe mal davon aus jetzt, ich muss mal die Specks angucken,
dass das mehr oder weniger das gleiche Board ist wie auf dem alten.
Und das geht, das geht.
Also ich habe einen Ultrawide HC2, glaube ich, das Ding, genau.
Das habe ich drüben bei mir im Wohnzimmer mit Dual-Tuner-TV-Stick.
Was mit TV-Hat-End macht, ist die Aufnahme für DVBC-Aufnahme.
Das ist halt eine Festplassie, dann sieht das genauso aus.
Exakt, so bloß, dass bei mir eine SSD drin ist.
Das Ding ist halt klein.
Das offizielle Image, was es dafür gab, war mega alt und scheiße, das stimmt.
Aber ich habe dann, ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr ganz sicher,
entweder habe ich aktuell einen Ubuntu drauf laufen oder einen Ambien.
Zumindest haben wir damals im Stream sogar einen eigenen Kernel für gebaut,
dass er den Dual-Tuner erkannt hat.
Aber ein halbes Jahr später oder so gab es was geupdatetes.
Und seitdem ist das ganz okay.
Und ich denke mal, das wird mit dem neuen auch ganz gut funktionieren.
Übrigens, das offizielle Gehäuse für das HC2 ist genauso hässlich.
Guckt euch das an.
Was denken die sich immer dabei, so Dinger zu bauen?
Auf der einen Seite bauen sie ganz gute Hardware
und dann versauen sie es komplett durch so ein kack Ding.
NS7, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscriptions wieder hier.
Ach nee, du hast einen Sub gegiftet, aber auch nice.
Wer hat denn was gekriegt? Der Hangman.
Hangman-Son.
Aijajaja.
Nice.
Der Otor C2, was war denn das für einer?
Ach, das war das Board.
Sind nicht mehr oder weniger überall der gleiche Kram drin?
Irgendein 8-Core-Rock-Blah, sonst was?
Frag mich nicht.
Was ich mir nicht merken kann, was drin ist.
Irgendein 8-Core-Ding mit 4 Schnellen und 4 Lahmen-Kernen.
Ist glaube ich überall das gleiche drin.
Rock, Rock, wie heißt die CPU?
Also ich Rock?
Ach nee.
Ja, aber 8-Corn ist schon mal richtig.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Ist auch egal.
So, gucken wir uns mal ein paar Videos an.
Das Betrugs-Business mit E-Books.
Ja, E-Books ist eh so ein Ding.
Das ist halt so typisch deutsche Taktik wieder.
Dass ein E-Book der gleiche Kram kostet wie ein normales Buch.
Können wir bitte nächstes Weihnachten dem ersten Stream auf Twitch mit der Programmiersprache Plan-Kalkül sehen?
Ja, alles klar.
Plan-Kalkül ist das Ding, womit man den allerersten Rechner programmiert hat.
Oder einer der ersten Rechner.
Ich glaube, das ist irgendwas für irgendeinen Zuse.
Frag mich nicht, sonst was?
Uralt.
Wahrscheinlich kann man das heute gar nicht mehr verwenden.
Da musstest du wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Röhren einbauen, um das zu programmieren.
Warum hat dir MW2 nie so richtig gefallen?
Naja, weil in MW2 bis heute übelst viel Bullshit drin ist, was dich random killt.
Also der Unterschied zwischen Core 4 und MW2 ist halt einfach, dass du Core 4 halbwegs kontrollieren kannst, was passiert.
Und da auch schon viel Bullshit drin ist.
Aber MW2 wirst du einfach random weggebashed.
Ohne dass du was gegenmachen kannst.
Also in MW2 ist so viel Crap drin.
Ich sag mal nur One-Man-Army-Danger-Clothes.
Und solche Dinger.
Akimbo-Shotguns.
So, also, jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Was haben wir denn jetzt?
Belocked, da, da, da, und tried, first look.
Faker's Sheets.
Da hab ich doch die ersten 5 Minuten aus der Woche geguckt, ey.
Es ist so offensichtlich, wie da beschissen wird.
Cyber-Parr, gut, na, nee, das muss ich mir eigentlich jetzt nicht geben.
Top 5 Speedrunning Moments 2020.
Greatest Battlefield Flanks.
Excellent.
Massive Flanks.
Das blockieren Bibidagi.
Ehrlich gesagt ist mir das eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Aber vielleicht sehen wir es los, tschüss bei.
So.
Oh, Battlefield 3 Flanks, Moment.
Wir haben Battlefield 4 Flanks und Battlefield 3 Flanks.
Jetzt wird da ein bisschen viel, oder?
So viele Flanks, Alter.
Außerdem haben wir das, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Ich glaub, das kennen wir schon, das Video.
Wenn es da eigentlich was Geiles gibt, was wir gucken müssen, Leute.
Also, also ich meine, was Interessantes.
Nicht wirklich was Geiles.
Weil das ist Monka Toss, das können wir natürlich nicht sehen.
Äh, dann sagt mir Bescheid.
So, also, was schauen wir uns jetzt?
Wir fangen, wisst ihr was?
Wir fangen, wir machen mal Easy Mode.
Wir gucken uns die Runde in MW2 an.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Ich hab schon lange keine MW2 mal geguckt.
Da kann ich mich wieder dran erinnern, dass in MW2 auch nicht alles geil war.
Der Typ ist glaube ich übelst am Flame über Cold War.
Kann das sein?
Ah, geht so.
Ja, sehr schwer.
Kann man, kann man das überhaupt noch auf dem PC spielen?
Es gab ja mal eine Zeit lang diese alte EV-Net,
Delta 4, irgendwas und jetzt noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch gibt und ob das überhaupt noch Leute spielen.
Zweier KD.
Oh ne, Disabo, Alter.
Das stimmt, gescheite Maps hatte MW2.
Teilweise, teilweise.
Es waren auch richtige Crap Maps dabei.
Wartet mal.
Diese Schneemap mit den Häusern, ich hab vergessen wie es heißt.
War zum Beispiel übelst Müll.
Ok, Rust ist Dreck.
Terminal ist gut.
Strike ist Remake ist auch gut.
Crash ist gut.
Overground ist Remake.
Gut, gut, gut.
Mavela ist ok.
East Hale ist auch in Ordnung.
Afghan ist gut.
Quarry ist ok.
Bailout kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Rundown ist glaube ich auch ein Remake.
Ist ok.
Ach Moment, nicht kein Remake.
Was labere ich denn?
Rundown war original.
Das war auch ganz ok.
D-Rail, D-Rail ist übelst Crap.
Salvage ist auch Crap.
Scrapyard ist gut.
Skidrawl ist ziemlich gut gewesen.
Storm kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern zeigen.
Subbase war auch ok.
Wavilla, Dings, Fuel.
Kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ist Fuel die Steils-Clown-Map?
Wavilla ist ok.
Terminal, Trailer Park ist die Steils-Clown-Map oder?
Ich glaube Trailer Park ist die Steils-Clown-Map.
Ja.
Die haben damals schon den gleichen Scheiß erzählen wie heute.
Jaja, ist ok.
Ich hängengeblieben.
Ja, Trailer Park hatten wir.
Das war naja, ging so.
Highrise, unpopuläre Meinung.
Ich fand Highrise gar nicht so geil.
Invasion war ok.
Underpass war ok.
Remake, Karachi war ok.
Wasteland ist auch so eine Map.
Die ist eigentlich übelst kacke.
Aber weil die ganzen AC130-Nuke-Farmer Wasteland gerne gespielt haben, ist die beliebt.
Aber an sich war Wasteland mega kacke.
Excellent.
So.
Also.
Oh, was ist das denn?
Was hältst du vom Aufsetzen eines Grafana-Dashboards zur Ausweitung verschiedener KPI?
Oh, was war KPI nochmal?
Das ist...
Nee, nee, nee.
Ist das Recovery-Time?
Alter, Abkürzung stellst.
Key Performance Indicator.
Alles klar.
Na ja, also rein ein Grafana-Dashboard da aufsetzen wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht so wirklich
in der Abschlussprüfung gerecht, aber du musstest den halt ordentlich verkaufen.
Zum Beispiel könntest du denen sagen, nicht dass du Grafana aufsetzt und da irgendwelche
Sachen zusammenklickst, weil das ist ein bisschen mau für ein Abschlussprojekt.
Du könntest zum Beispiel in die Richtung machen, dass du sagst, Evaluierung von Charting-Tools
zur Darstellung von Performance-Kritischen, was weiß ich, Auswertung, Performance-Kritische,
irgendwas in der Richtung.
Weil dann kannst du das Ganze schon mal ein bisschen IHK-Style aufplänen.
Die stehen nämlich drauf, wenn du eine Produktauswahl machst, das finden die ganz besonders geil.
Da machst du dann so ein paar Tabellen und sagst, du hast dir Grafana angeguckt, du hast
dir Dings, wie heißt das andere, Chronograph angeguckt, du hast dir Graphema, was so alles
da so gibt, hast dir angeguckt und zufälligerweise gewinnt halt Grafana, weil du das halt machen
willst.
Zumindest auf so Produktauswahlsachen stehen die, weil die sind ja immer noch der Meinung
bei der IHK, der Fachinformatiker ist zur Hälfte Kaufmann.
Falls ihr das nicht wusstet Leute, ich bin auch zur Hälfte Kaufmann.
Ich weiß auch, weil ich da so richtig das Beste, Beste, ja.
Genau, also irgendwie, also rein das reicht nicht, aber wenn du Produktauswahl rein machst,
ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, da kann der Grafana gewinnen.
Bei mir hat auch OpenVPN damals gewonnen.
Ich hab VPN-Tools ausgewählt.
Heute wird natürlich ExpressVPN gewinnen.
Im Prinzip hab ich auch nicht wirklich viel gemacht.
Gut, aber meine Abschlussprüfung war eh fail, das hab ich euch ja schon ein paar Mal
erzählt.
Ich bin ja durch meine Abschlussprüfung durchgefallen, bevor ich die Abschlussprüfung überhaupt
gemacht hab, bis die IHK festgestellt hat, das ergibt irgendwie keinen Sinn.
Das hab ich euch ja schon öfters erzählt, richtig fail.
Also natürlich bin ich am Ende nicht durchgefallen, aber die IHK hat gesagt, ich bin durchgefallen.
Ja, also da muss man noch ein bisschen was machen.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Es kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, wo du landest, aber ich glaube, das ist prinzipiell
durch die Bank weg bei den meisten so, dass die da Ansicht sind, Fachinformatiker ist
zu helfen, Kaufmann, und wenn du so ein bisschen Stonksachen mit drinne hast, Produktauswahl
oder vielleicht auch was sich der Kram kostet und sowas, bisschen Kalkulationssachen, das
sehen sie glaube ich alle gern.
Ich glaube, das mögen sie alle.
Wo war denn das Video hier jetzt?
Ah, hier.
Produktauswahl kommt sowieso rein, ja dann ist gut.
Ja, die Map geht, ich hab irgendwas mal gesagt, die Map geht, das ist Subbase, aber fand
ich jetzt auch nicht so geil.
Erst mal UMP, erst mal UMP Silencer.
Aber einen Vorteil hatte MW2 wirklich, das war so viel scheiß OP, dass schon wieder
nix OP war, weil wenn es irgendwie 20 Sachen gibt, die OP sind, dann ist es halt normal.
Aber in 2020 über MW2 aufregend ist ja eh.
Erst mal hier Striker, bam.
Sollte euch mal aufgefallen, dass die früher Waffenlizenzen hatten und jetzt in Cold War
und Modern Warfare nicht mehr?
In MW2 und in C4 und so, da hießen die Waffen noch so, wie sie in echt hießen, ja.
Du hattest einen UMP, du hattest eine M16, du hattest einen Spast, du hattest sonst was
und in Modern Warfare heißt die UMP jetzt glaube ich Holger und sowas.
Wann Holger?
Warum ausgerechnet Holger?
Ist zu teuer Waffenlizenzen zu kaufen gewesen, das können die sich nicht leisten bei ihrem
Budget.
Oder es könnte auch komplett andere Logik dahinter stecken, dass sie zum Beispiel nicht
wollen, dass man mit echten Waffen in Verbindung gebracht wird.
Oder dass man ihnen nicht nachsagen kann, sie sponsoren oder sie supporten die Waffenlobby
oder irgendwas.
Da hängt ja manchmal viel mehr dran, als man so auf den ersten Blick sieht.
Aber ich fände es trotzdem cool, wenn die sich mal wieder Waffenlizenzen kaufen würden.
Bam.
Alter, da hätte ich mich da aufgeregt.
Ich hätte so gekotzt, ich hätte Instant Rage Quitted, ich sage es euch.
Ich hätte nicht einfach nur Rage Quitted, Quit to Dashboard, ich hätte Konsole ausgeschaltet,
direkt drauf gedrückt.
Oh, ich hätte so extrem Rage Quitted, das könnt ihr euch nicht...
Hier, hier.
Hätte ich den Rage...
Ich hätte so krass ge-Rage Quitted.
Alter, der Typ!
Was ist das für ein...
Alter, der Gegner, das ist ja die schlimmste Art von Gegner aller Zeiten.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Der Gegner, der kommt mit Painkiller von draußen, hat schon mal die Noob-Tube-Shotted,
den anderen Dings Noob-Tube-Launcher, versucht ihn abzubashen.
One-Man-Army-Kommando hat...
Also, das ist ja der Abfahrt hoch 10.
Wer weiß, wie fünf Monate.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Und dann kommt er noch rein und kommandot ihn mit dem Messer.
Oh, nee.
Was man aber auch schön daran sieht, ist,
wie schön das Ganze ohne Skill-Base Matchmaking ist.
Ich meine, das ist garantiert nicht das erste Game, das er spielt.
Der Typ ist gut.
Also dort spielt der Spiel wirklich nicht schlecht.
Aber das war vielleicht die fünfte Lobby oder so.
Und es hat da ein paar Bobs erwischt.
Erst mal voll durch die Wand rassiert.
Ich habe meine Zweifel, dass eine echte UMP durch so eine Wand durchschießt.
Es ist nicht sogar so, dass die echte UMP normalerweise mit Anti-Personen-Dings ausgestattet ist.
Also sprich Kugeln, die halt gar nicht gut penetraten durch Wände.
Ja, ab und zu habe ich noch Kontakt mit dem Kaboom.
Selten.
Das liegt aber zum größten Teil an mir, weil ich voller Spaß bin, was soziale Sachen angeht
und einfach nicht antworte.
Ihr kennt mich ja.
Ne, das ist keine P90.
Achso, du meinst das mit dem Ausgestein?
Ja, das kann auch sein.
Doch, doch, die UMP hat doch standardmäßig Anti-Personen-Dings drin, oder?
Ah, naja, egal.
Genau, der Meebs.
So sieht es aus.
Und die penetraten ja nicht so gut.
Ne, die UMP ist nicht 9mm.
Die MP5 ist 9mm.
Das weiß ich noch aus Zeiten, wo ich mich für die Waffen in Call of Duty interessiert habe.
Wenn wir jetzt hier so richtig Kokona-Mensch am Start hätten, der wüsste sofort Bescheid.
Da könnt ihr das alles sagen.
Ich habe ein Video geguckt von einem auf YouTube.
Der hat ein Video von seiner Katze gepostet, wie die irgendwie Weihnachtsgeschenke auspackt.
Und er hat dann halt auch, also die Katze hat irgendwie ihre Weihnachtsgeschenke ausgepackt
und er hat seine Weihnachtsgeschenke ausgepackt.
Es war halt typisches, typisches Freedom-Video.
Die Katze packt halt Spielzeug aus, ja.
Und das erste, was er auspackt, ist erstmal eine Pistole.
Ich war ganz okay.
Nur in den USA, ja.
Gut, es mag bestimmt die ein oder anderen Länder auch noch geben, wo das so ist.
Aber, ähm...
Alter.
Genau.
Ja, ja.
Und weil das Ding eine sehr effektive Mannstopp-Wirkung hat, penetratet es sicherlich nicht so gut durch Wände.
Weil eins und das andere geht ja nicht.
Ne, aber das Video war auch geil.
Sie zeigt da seine Katze.
Ich denke auch, niedliche Katze, wie sie das Zeug aufmacht und alles.
Und dann geht er erstmal und sagt, so, okay, jetzt packe ich mal das Weihnachtsgeschenk aus,
was mir mein Bruder geschenkt hat.
Und was packt er aus?
Erstmal eine Pistole.
So, und dann kam der Hit in dem Video.
Packt erstmal die richtige Corner-Side, packt die Pistole aus.
Und sagt so, ah, cool, hier, nice Pistole.
Aber, und dann greift er sich so hinten an den Bund und hält die andere Pistole daneben und sagt, aber die habe ich schon.
Dann hat er die gleiche Pistole einfach schon einstecken gehabt.
Naja.
Ist halt andere Welt, ja.
Freedom, Alter.
Freedom.
I think it's cheating, dude.
Someone's got to be cheating or something, dude.
Eat stool, will ya.
Oh, my dude got an AC130 in his carry package.
Akimbo steady aim.
I had a chopper.
Bam.
Jetzt.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Calling it in, baby, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
6 chopper gunner right here.
How do I go thermal?
F?
Achtung, Chopper gar nicht so.
D-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Tritt ritt tritt tritt tritt
Dippertipp heyy
yo
Frank
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange ich nur schiebe.
Ist das Miniscule Health oder was?
Was ist mit diesem Spiel passiert?
Es gibt keine Art, dass ich ein Neukon habe.
Ja, es gibt keine Art, dass ich ein Neukon habe.
Wenn etwas mit diesem Spiel passiert, dann ist dieser Mann schief.
Jemand hat etwas in diesem Spiel verändert und hat alles kaputt gemacht.
Ich spiele meist nicht auf dem PC. Ich weiß nicht, ob es so schlecht ist, wenn du nicht mit einem Neukon aussteigst.
Oh, warte, ich bin gestorben.
Ich hätte definitiv einen Neukon gehabt.
Und warte, der Schuss geht weiter. Was ist los?
Jemand in diesem Spiel hat etwas gemacht.
Sorry, es war ein bisschen laut.
Oh, ja, da ist es.
Ein fliegendes Donut. Das ist mein Guess.
Eigentlich ist dieser Mann verbunden.
Ich werde dieses Spiel verlassen. Das ist einfach witzig.
Das ist einfach witzig.
Ich habe Cast Ruins. Die haben keinen schmutzigen Schimmer.
Die installieren sich von komischen China-Seiten und fühlen sich wie der Hacker-Man.
Zumal es nicht schwierig ist, so ein altes Spiel zu erspringen.
Was zum größten Teil noch P2P ist.
Da kannst du ja alles machen was du willst
Also eins muss man ja sagen was
Was MW2 hat so eine Sache
Die Sniper haben alle so komische Namen
Also die Typen die hauptsächlich
Moment
Ich hab mich verguckt
Der Typ mit dem Snipername wurde von der Sniper
gekillt
Weil eigentlich
ist so ein richtig krasser Quickscope Snipername
Was so mit dem Kabum Friseur
Der Kabum der spielt glaube ich sowas gar nicht mehr
und der Friseur auch nicht
Ich bin der einzige der auch so Games hängen geblieben ist
Wisst ihr was der Kabum spielt
Das kann ich jetzt mal kurz revealen
Weil das hat er mir letztens erzählt
Der spielt Hunter Call of the Wild
Hat er mir letztens mal erzählt
So
Krasser Jagd Simulation Stels
Was sie
Das Arma für Jäger
Arma 3 für Jäger
Kannst Buffalo's Bashen
Das soll aber wirklich
Ja ja ich hab mir auch die Steam Bewertung durchgelesen
Das kann wirklich gar nicht so schlecht sein
Alter
Rückstoß gibt es in dem Game auch nicht oder
Rückstoß gab es in MW2 nicht
Ne
Overrated
Du weißt ja was
Nuke in MW2 war viel zu einfach
Ich sag's euch wie es ist
Man hat sich damals zwar wieder
Megakrasse Ultraskiller gefühlt
Wenn man
Eine Nuke gemacht hat, aber Nuke war in MW2
Einfach, viel zu einfach
Ich mein wenn die das Game vielleicht nicht beendet hätten
Wenn man hätte
Weiterspielen können, okay
Alter Heli Pilot was mit dir los
You're doing the wrong thing pal
Choppergunner really does not want me to get the Nuke dude
Flying me to absolutely nowhere
Enemy Choppergunner
Tell me how
You're top guys 11 and 21
I'm so screwed man
I'm so screwed we're at 6700 I don't have a chance
Six bullets in this
Eight shots maybe
And I have a striker and that's it
Jawoll
Ja das frage ich mich auch
Pepega Gegner
Ein Game ist gleich vorbei
I don't know how close I was dude that sucks
That would have been a sick Nuke too
Would have been a sick Nuke dude we're still freaking
Massive Nuke
For some reason the connection is so bad
So so bad
Ja die Moab war glaub schwieriger
Als die Nuke in MW2
War es nicht so dass die angefangen haben bei der Moab
Dass du keine Killstreak Kills machen konntest
Sondern alles von Hand machen musstest
Ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern
Da ist die Moab
Muss jetzt mal kurz
Muss noch mal kurz sein
Da ist die Moab
Jawoll
Falls das überhaupt noch irgendjemand kennt
Das Ding hat ja auch keine Recoil
Da ist er
Der Schneibermann war da
Der Schneibermann war da der wollte gerade rauskommen
Also Free4all ohne Schalter im Verginger gar nicht
Das ist ein Kill, stimmt zwar MW3
Hatten die nicht beim Shopper Gunner und beim Gunship
Hatten die dann nicht die Controls Inverted
Dass du nicht so einfach triffst
Oh jetzt schreckt
Kennst du noch Tapes? Ja klar
Und ist er Host geworden?
Wahrscheinlich ist er Host geworden und out jetzt alle
Ja wobei
Der ist auf den Fenster gefallen
Wobei er könnte Host sein, guck mal wie schnell die Gegner fallen
Also der Host Vorurteil im MW2 und Black Ops 1 war huge
Oh kacke wie es laggt
Massive lag
Das meine ich übrigens
Das ist das warum mir MW2 nie gefallen hat
Unter anderem so richtig gut gefallen hat
Weil du einfach zu jeder Zeit random durch irgendeinen Kacke sterben konntest
Ist heute nicht besser
Aber halt kein Vergleich zu Code 4
Aber die MW2 Voice Samples sind auch immer noch geil
Black Ops 1, ne da gab es keine richtigen Server
Vielleicht auf dem PC
Moment Moment
Hat er die Farmers ohne rote Tiger Streifen? Was ist da los?
Das geht aber nicht
Tango Sucker
Bepäger
Kann sich jemand noch an den Blackbird erinnern? Klar, bester Killstück hast du recht
Blackbird ist der beste Killstück in allen Call of Duty 2
Weil der recht low war
Es gab ja danach noch Orbitalensattel und sonst was
Die haben glaub ich alles mehr gebraucht
Ich glaub der Orbi war 11 Kills, ne?
Da kann ich gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern
Der Blackbird war ziemlich sicher 7 Kills
Und
Deswegen hast du gespielt in Black Ops 1
Du hast JV, Blackbird und Hunde oder sowas gespielt
Also 3 7 11 war das dann
Und 4 Kills zu machen mit Blackbird war kein großartiges Ding
In your face
Ich glaub Heartline hat man nicht gespielt
Weil man musste doch quasi Ghost spielen
Ghost Pro, Alter
Ne, das war ein anderer Slot, ne?
Black Ops 1
Ghost war das blaue, das mittlere
Und Heartline war das nicht das rote Perk?
Was war das was man immer gespielt hat in Black Ops 1 was so geflamed wird?
Ghost Pro und Dead Silence oder so, ne?
Oder was war das was immer so geflamed wurde?
Ghost und Ninja Pro, Ninja Pro, genau
Die sitzen alle im Haus
Oh, der schlägt ein
Ne, doch nicht
Ja gut, Fingerfertigkeit fand ich vollkommen ok
Weil, warte mal, wie hieß das nochmal auf Englisch?
Ich hab den Kram immer eigentlich nur auf Englisch gespielt, war das Quick?
Ne, was war Fingerfertigkeit Pro nochmal auf Englisch?
Slide of Hand, Slide of Hand, genau
Das war ok
Du musstest ja dich bewegen und schießen und ziehen
Du musstest ja das Spiel spielen
Für Slide of Hand
Vollkommen in Ordnung, ja
Aber Ghost haben die Leute in der dunklen Ecke gesessen und haben sich nicht bewegt
Fuck you last stand
A Kimbo UMP Sachen gibts
Das ist richtiger Rotz, A Kimbo UMP, Alter
Guckt euch das an
Ja gut, im Nahkampf rotzt du damit alles weg
Weggenugt
Primo noch in 13 Monaten, Dankeschön
Hype
Endes last stand Video haben wir uns das letzte Mal eingeguckt
Die 18 A Kimbo war auch heftig, ja
Da muss ich drehen
Wie oft muss ich ihm das noch sagen?
Messern und drehen
Messern und drehen, sonst ist es keine legit new, geht nicht
Einfach, es ist einfach nicht
Nicht accepted
Nicht, nicht, nicht valid, ja
Geht nicht
Beste A Kimbo Leute, beste A Kimbo war Model A Kimbo
Beste, beste, beste
Model 1887 A Kimbo
Und die haben das ja damals gepatcht, als es zu OP war
Und die haben das so
Die haben das so lieblos gepatcht, dass du einfach nur ein Attachment ändern musstest
Und es war wieder genauso OP wie vorher, wenn nicht sogar mehr OP
Ja, ja
Ja, ja, ja
Ok, das ist ja kwa-
Das ist ja typisch, ey, das ist echt krass Kartoffel Qualität, ey
Auf, ich will A Kimbo, ich will A Kimbo Models sehen
Zeig mir A Kimbo Models, Alter
Ja, bam
Der spiel das falsch du musst abwechslend schießen du musst abwechslend schießen kollege
viel besser
Wobei, ne ne ne stimmt gar nicht dass du abwechslend schießen musstest du konntest abwechslend schießen aber für bessere range hast du
Beide gleichzeitig geschossen du hast über die halbe map wohnschottet guckt euch das an Das war so peders teil
Das ist mega unfair
Das ist so p gewesen der shit ich erinnere mich noch ich erinnere mich noch oder capture zu gar was mit dem los
Das war schon heftig op das ding
Der hatte nicht mal getroffen das ist xbox das ist normal auf der xbox konntest du vorbeischießen hast trotzdem getroffen war kein problem
So jetzt gucken wir uns als nächstes an wir gucken uns top top speedrun moments in 2020 an
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich habe dieses jahr diese ganze speedrunning geschichte gar nicht so sehr verfolgt
Ich habe aber auch das ist ein problem was ich habe ich vielleicht kennt das jemand umso mainstream ega was wird umso weniger interessiere ich mich dafür
Irgendwie merkwürdig ich habe früher total viele speedruns und ich habe auch noch so viele speedruns gemacht
Und seitdem das quasi fast fast fast schon mainstream ist interessiert mich nicht mehr großartig das liegt aber auch ein bisschen daran was einher geht mit mit mainstream werden
Vergleicht mal beispielsweise die alten games done quick events mit den neuen die neuen sind so klatt poliertes belangloses zeug irgendwie ja da wird so ein bisschen komplizierter
darauf geachtet dass keiner irgendwie mal was falsches sagt was falsches anhat was sonst was hat das nervt mich
Dein mario speedrun video war das erste mal dass ich davon gehört habe ja das war ja auch schon ganz schön lang her es ist ja wahrscheinlich 2015 oder so gewesen
2013 sogar guck mal 2013 das haben viele geguckt ich weiß gar nicht ob es hier noch überhaupt noch gibt
Hast du auf deine main account youtube premium nö warum youtube red alter wer braucht das
Gucken wir mal was die top speedrun moments in 2010 waren
2020 nicht 2010 wenn ich das mikro benutze ich habe seit jahren dieses headset hier ich weiß ich habe mal ein video zu gemacht das headsets nix taugen aber die ausnahmen bestätigen die regeln
das ding beide also das beide namens mx 300 und das mikrofon verwende ich auch hier im stream weil es einfach angenehm ist wenn man was auf dem kopf hat und sich nicht
irgendwie so mikro positionieren muss oder so videos nehme ich manchmal noch mit dem blue yeti auf wobei ich die letzten videos das blue yeti gar nicht verwenden konnte weil ich nicht weiß wo ich es hingestellt habe
so ok was waren die top speedrun moments 2020 das stimmt minecraft ist voll beliebt mittlerweile speedrun technisch
ja es gibt jedes jahr scheiße und 2021 wird auch nicht besser da gibt es einfach nur andere scheiße
der typ hört sich immer ein und schläft da klar ein was will man denn in minecraft speedrun ja ich hoffe der zeigt warte mal ab das ist richtig advanced mittlerweile minecraft speedrunning
und was bei minecraft speedrunning übelst übelst nice ist gar nicht so der speedrun an sich die haben die also du brauchst ja richtig richtig gutes rng dass du minecraft schnell speedrunnen kannst
und es gibt zwei kategorien in minecraft speedrun es gibt einmal die kategorie random seed und es gibt die kategorie fixed seed also sprich da wo du beim welten kreieren wo du halt eine nummer eingibst und dann ist die welt immer gleich
und es gibt mittlerweile so eine riesen competition oder gab es ich glaube mittlerweile ist der rekord so gut dass das auch ein bisschen ein bisschen abgeschwächt ist aber es gab eine riesen competition wer die besten seeds findet
ich weiß nicht wie sie das gemacht haben wahrscheinlich haben sie da irgendwelche rechner einen ganzen tag laufen lassen die die minecraft seeds durchprobiert haben
und die haben dann seeds gesucht die beispielsweise ender portals hatten die schon quasi fast voll waren und wo direkt ein dorf nebendran ist und so was also im prinzip die meisten minecraft speedruns rekorde kam daher weil ein neuer noch mehr op seed gefunden wurde
achja und was ich mitbekommen habe dieses jahr es gab jede menge neue ocarina of time rekorde und das lag daran weil man das spiel also man musste ocarina of time ja bisher schon nicht mehr ansatzweise durchspielen
aber man musste immerhin noch den letzten dungeon machen und den endgegner besiegen und mittlerweile gibt es einen glitch dass man quasi direkt also nicht zum endgegner kommt sondern direkt in abspann springen kann aus dem starter dorf
ich hoffe das zeigen sie das total abgedreht aber du kommst aus dem aus den aus aus kokiri forest kommst du direkt in die credits mittlerweile was ist das half life icon ein ein terminal
aber ich finde schön dass du das half life icon nennst endlich mal man of culture hier
also das das braucht man jetzt gar nicht mehr der endgegner besiegen und so braucht man nicht mehr
d.
Ja
Das stimmt, allerdings ist die ist der Doom Eternal Speedrun, der wo so gesprungen wird, ist total langweilig
Es wird einfach nur rumgesprungen, es wird kaum was gekillt und sonst total langweilig
Was viel geiler ist, was richtig geil anzusehen ist, sind die Doom Eternal Speedruns, die das Spiel spielen
Und die sind richtig, also die sind wirklich gut die Leute
Die treffen jeden Schuss ey, also die sind wirklich heftig drauf
Was ist deine Meinung zu TAS?
War gut
Das ist so, wie wäre nämlich mal was deine Meinung zu Schach
Das ist halt ein komplett eigenes Ding, also hat ja mit Speedrun von Hand nichts zu tun
Das ist ähnlich so dazu, wie wenn man das halt programmiert
Es ist ja im Prinzip, du programmierst den Input dafür
Ich finde es ist eine coole Sache, wo man halt sieht was möglich ist
Ich persönlich finde es nicht so spannend
Also ich gucke mir nicht gerne TAS an, ich finde es viel besser, wenn die Leute selbst spielen
Da habe ich mich echt mal verschätzt
Ich habe ja 2000, frag mich nicht, 15, 16 oder so gedacht, ach komm Minecraft, das hat voll den Hype
Aber in zwei Jahren interessiert das keinen mehr
Ich lag echt falsch
Minecraft war immer wieder populär auf YouTube, aber die Speedrun-Szene war extrem nötig
Und nicht viele Leute nahmen es ernsthaft
Als das Jahr begann, war es nicht in den Top 20 aktiven Spielen auf speedrun.com
Jetzt ist es weit weg, Nummer 1
Es ist verrückt, wie schnell die Landschaft verändern kann
Und es lässt mich unglaublich...
Das da aber finde ich cool, Mario 64 ist seit Jahren einfach voll mit dabei
Es ist aber auch geil zu sehen
Before we close out the year, let's take a look at my picks for the top 5 speedrunning moments of 2020
For those that won't make it to the end of this video, I want to wish you a very Merry Christmas
And I hope that you have a fantastic holiday
Now before we go on, I have a very important shoutout to this video sponsor, keeps.com
The sad reality is that 2 out of 3 men will experience hair loss by the time they're 35
Is this belongs for Apple?
Is this to bait?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, meint er das ernst oder ist das Verarschung?
Fuck, der meint das ernst?
Alter das ist alles so krasser Scam
Und was man nicht vergessen darf, das Zeug bringt ja alles nichts wenn man schon kein Hahn mehr hat
Die Leute sind wirklich gut in dem Game
Und das ist nicht die Kategorie wo man über die ganze Map springt, ihr müsst mal gucken wie die teilweise die Gegner beim Spawn direkt aimen
Alter das ist echt krass
Alter das ist krass
Das stimmt
Das ist auf jeden Fall cool
Ich mein guck mal wie der die Dinge da weg aimed, seht ihr das?
Der weiß dass der Kram da spawned und erstmal hat Ben Railgunned
Weil er gerade sagt Bowser, was mich ja immer noch voll verwirrt ist dass der neue Chef von Nintendo America Bowser heißt
Also seht ihr mal heutzutage kann man Speedrun Pro sein, damit Geld verdienen
Ich mein es hat alles seine Vor- und Nachteile wenn Sachen Mainstream werden
Der gute Stundenton ist es nicht, aber dass du immerhin da mit vom Waffen überhaupt mal irgendwie was siehst
On the 27th of August the speedrunner Zost achieved back to back world records in Super Metroid
Super Metroid is one of the most respected games in speedrunning
Ich bin ja riesen Super Nintendo Fan, das war ja so meine erste richtige, ich hatte zwar einen Gameboy vorher aber das war so meine erste richtige Konsole in Super Nintendo
Ich finde das ist bis heute das Nintendo Game was am meisten horrormäßig ist
Weil die Dinger sehen alle übelst zum fürchten aus, auch dieses große Krokodil was es da gibt, ich hab vergessen wie es heißt
Der Krokodil Boss, Krokodil ich weiß nicht wie der Boss heißt, ja das war voll zum fürchten damals das Zeug
Das Ding und vor dem Ding hatte ich auch übelst Schiss
Also ich hatte Angst vor Super Metroid damals, weil es so gruselig war
Ja Half-Life Alex habe ich nicht gespielt, weil ich nicht einsehe mir für ein Game in 3D Dings zu kaufen
Ich installiere keinen Sponsor Block, weil wenn ich mir schon Videos von anderen Leuten angucke, dann gucken wir uns auch Sellout von anderen Leuten an
Haha Chat alter Lul
Ist das G-Bane oder meinst du das wirklich Ernste?
Kein Quake Alter
Ok das ist natürlich nicht schlecht, erstmal Weltrekord gehst Penn, nächster Weltrekord easy
Da hatte ich auch übelst Schiss davor, am Ende explodiert das ja und du musst zu deinem Raumschiff flüchten
Ich habe mir auch in die Hose geschissen als ich klein war
So 1900 frag mich nicht wann war das? 1993 oder so müsste das in dem Dreh gewesen sein, wann kam das raus?
1994 ok irgendwie so in dem Dreh, da war ich 10 mit 10 mit 10 kackt man sich bei so einem Game in die Hose
Stellt sich bei dem Game raus, dass Samus eine Frau ist, ich glaube Samus, dass Samus eine Frau ist hat man schon im NES Original im Abspann gesehen
Ok ich würde sagen hat sich gefreut, kann er wahrscheinlich auch, denn wahrscheinlich hat er 27 Billionen mal das Game neu gestartet
Ich finde es geil ey, ohne Scheiß ich bewundere die Leute teilweise wie die schaffen dran zu bleiben an Games, dass sie irgendwie keine Ahnung spielen
Die Games irgendwie für 10 Jahre haben die irgendwie schon 35.000 mal neu gestartet und spielen das Game irgendwie jeden Tag 8 Stunden so nach dem Motto und den wird es nicht langweilig, also nicht schlecht
Und jetzt beschwert sich hier bestimmt gleich jemand und in den Kommentaren, es kann nicht sein dass man den alten YouTube Channel sieht hier, geht ja gar nicht
Gibt bestimmt irgendjemand die Statue aufgeregt haben in den Comments
Ich glaube jeder der mal der Speedrunning zuerst entdeckt und hat entweder den Ocarina of Time Speedrun oder den Mario 64 Speedrun als erstes gesehen
Eventuell wenn einer richtig oldschool ist auch Quake oder so, aber ich glaube die meisten haben das erste was die Speedrunning gesehen haben ist Mario 64 oder Ocarina of Time und waren bei beiden total verwirrt weil sie für das Game irgendwie 5 Wochen gebraucht haben und die man es halt easy as fuck durchspielen
Aber das stimmt schon, es gibt kaum was was so optimal ist wie Ocarina of Time
Vielleicht das original Mario ist auch optimalist as fuck, im original Mario ist es ja sogar so dass du nicht wirklich mehr Zeit sparen kannst weil du müsstest quasi so und so viel Frames drunter kommen dass die Zeit überhaupt zählt oder so was ganz merkwürdig
Deswegen sind originale Mario Speedruns auch so extrem rare wenn es da irgendwie mal was Neues gibt
Ich glaube die meisten Geniusen die da waren haben die Problemsolvung und Theoriecrafting keine neuen Ways um das Spiel zu brechen
Wir haben sogar Narcissa Wright sich selbst ein paar alte Rekorde erzielt, was toll war zu sehen
Das größte Take away für mich war dass ihr niemals fest glauben müsstet dass unser aktuelles Wissen überhaupt optimal ist
Und egal wie hoch ein Rekord geht, gibt es immer eine gute Chance dass ein neues Stück Information kommt, was komplett absoluten
Und die Ingenieurität der Speedrunners
Alles klar oder?
Also das ist das was ich meinte du kannst jetzt aus dem Start Dorf kannst du zu den Credits swappen
Die Katze hat sich erschrocken ja
Guck mal, Alter, oh die arme Katze, die arme Katze
Alter was geht mit dem Herrchen ab
Aber eins wo ich sagen spannender wird der Orkarina aus Time Speedrun dadurch nicht
Weil es gibt ja es gibt ja Speedruns also beispielsweise auch dieser Doom Eternal Speedrun wo du über die ganze Map springst
Der ist zwar schneller aber er ist halt langweilig zu gucken
Und ich finde der Orkarina auf Time Speedrun wird dadurch nicht wirklich interessanter
Hallo Doomie
GoldenEye finde ich übrigens auch total langweilig zu gucken weil 90 Prozent der Zeit auf die Erde geguckt wird
Es ist halt nicht spannend zu gucken oder? Mal ernsthaft
Deswegen gucke ich immer noch gerne Mario Speedruns Mario Speedruns sind immer noch pock
Und das gute an Mario ist dass es mehrere Kategorie also Mario 4 und 6 dass mehrere Kategorien gibt die unterschiedlich lang dauern
Man kann genau gucken also es ist was längeres zu gucken was kürzeres zu gucken und in den ganzen Kategorien passiert auch immer irgendwas
Deswegen ich würde nach wie vor sagen Mario 64 ist immer noch so mein liebstes liebstes zu gucken Speedrun Game
Und ich habe schon viele Mario 64 Speedruns geguckt
Ich meine das ist echt langweilig
Stimmt ich kann mich noch an die Schusshaut in dem Game erinnern
Das Game war übelst gut
Eines der besten Lizenz Games
Das muss ja kommen
Das kann ich mir immer wieder angucken
Das kannst du mit dem N64 Controller noch gar nicht richtig spielen oder
Wenn du das mit dem N64 Controller spielst musst du jeden Monat dir einen neuen Controller kaufen weil das Stick kaputt ist
Das ist das Video wo er halbnackt vorm Rechner aus Asien ich kann mich daran erinnern
Jetzt kommt gleich der Vater rein und freut sich mit ihm zusammen
Ich fühle mich dann voll irritierend dass er da halbnackt vorm Rechner sitzt und Speedrun
Das war auch so ein Live Event
Ich würde mich bei so etwas erst freuen wenn ich wirklich das letzte eingesammelt hätte
Nicht dass die Konsole noch krascht oder irgendwas
Ich habe mich da wo ich klein war voll schwer getan Bowser zu treffen immer
Ich würde mich da wo ich klein war voll schwer getan Bowser zu treffen immer
Ich würde mich da wo ich klein war voll schwer getan Bowser
zu treffen immer
Ich würde mich da wo ich klein war voll schwer getan Bowser zu treffen immer
Ich würde mich da wo ich klein war voll schwer getan Bowser